what are little sisters for if not to
call you out on your stuff
and keep you humble it's a beautiful
thing
and that's just what khloe kardashian
did to her big sis
kim kardashian on instagram tuesday oh
no
yeah so the kkw beauty founder shared
this pic on her insta story
serving some serious judgy eyes and
writing on the post quote
me judging people who aren't plant-based
jk
i don't judge jk i do well coco wasn't
feeling all that judgment
and reposted kim's story to her own
account
replying quote listen cutie pie you've
been plant-based for a few months
calm down we are trying to catch up is
it just me
or is there nothing more upsetting than
someone telling you to calm down
we'll just have to wait and see of
course last month
kim revealed that she and chloe were
partnering up to take their health to a
whole new level
the mom of four said she and the good
american founder would be upping their
workouts and
changing their diet for the month of
january sharing this shot
and writing sister boot camp starts this
month
plant-based and two workouts a day for
30 days to get our mind
and body right this year i think working
on
your personal growth internally is
something that will be a forever
mission listen i'll have whatever
they're having
because the sisters recently jetted off
for a girls getaway to turks and caicos
and flaunted the fruits of their labor
in some itty bitty bikinis
and they looked straight fire thank you
of course the 40 year old reality star's
plan to get her mind and body right
comes amid rumors she and her hubby
kanye west are heading for a divorce
we have different views sometimes but
that's my husband you know
a source previously told et that while
kim and the 43 year old rapper may be
ending their romantic relationship
they are still on good terms when it
comes to the four kids they share
together
seven-year-old north five-year-old saint
three-year-old chicago
and one-year-old psalm at the end of the
day kim and kanye will do what is best
for their kids and are on great terms as
[Music]
parents